hominid trace is beautiful right it's
definitely not Boston here we go okay so
what do you think wow this whole place
is ours
I even got him to throw in a whole
forest as a new backyard
you know Amy last night you said
something interesting at the after the
premiere you said this movie pet
cemeteries has everything you want in a
genre film and so I'm curious what's
your what's your checklist as a veteran
of genre films well I mean you want to
be entertained and you want to be taken
on an emotional roller coaster that's
why people want to go to a genre film is
they want to laugh and they want to
laugh at like kind of excuse me
screwed up stuff that's the PG version
of that line but that you know they want
to laugh and cathartic Lee experience
sort of the horror of life or death or
face death in some way but also
cathartic ly be able to laugh laugh at
moments and then be scared of moments
and not have to face it in real life
like you could go to a genre movie and
be able to laugh at their pain you know
yeah yeah it's like oh they're like I'm
okay but this is terrifying for them
yeah yeah eat that blend good yeah Jason
for you what was the creepiest sort of
part of your performance working with a
cat that comes back from the dead or a
kid that comes back from the dead was
pretty you know was not a nice you know
I mean that whole that scene in the
bathtub you know with the staples on the
back of the head you know it's funny
watching that last night because you
know she's you know when he digs her up
and the as bodies are that made up by
mortician and I knew what was coming and
you could just feel the audience with
the hair washing their hair so it's a
beautiful clean water on the down long
black hair and then it just has to be
tough to comb out you'd already seen it
with the cat so you know you're in self
but it's not gonna win well whatever
happens it and then just parts it and
there it is these staples down the back
of a head and the oh my god that's right
they did I feel like we're living sort
of in a cat asan's right now cats are
having a moment every cat on the big
screen somebody that somebody said to me
meow is our time you know cat lover
responded three last time be ours
what was it like sort of working with
you know churches and I kind of cat what
was it like worse is an iconic kid isn't
he mm he's a serious cat I love that I
mean I thought the choice feeling a real
card and sticking with that not having
some robot weird walking cart years um
you know the book he walks differently
you know but we just went with a cat
that just looked different it was there
that was you know a character out of a
spaghetti western you know those long
yeah but you see look well the cats come
back down the road it's just like
everywhere I looked it was like you been
I went through our range of expressions
of this cats looking at me I'm looking
at you cat to you look at me get on look
at you do what a cat's do looking at me
okay cat we'll look at each other it's
all that seeds of like what you're
looking at cat I see you seeing Mason
Mason here in the woods today
la discovered a charming little land
work but that secretary
place to bury our pets and remember them
when it seems scary but it's not
perfectly natural
just like dying is natural old towns
been using this place for generations
folks make a kind of ritual out of it
this movie I think it's great that you
play the sweetest character in a movie
and also the scariest movie which one
was more fun to play um there are both
really fun because I could I got to see
like Ellie's like evil motives and I got
to also see her like her sweet motives
so it was cool to see like how different
they were yeah and so when you're
playing you know did did you did you are
you familiar with the the first film and
sort of the how it was it was switched
in terms of the characters I think I
think they probably chose like an older
kid to do um like evil part because they
probably thought that they like might
understand the motives of the character
more and like maybe get like more into
the character and what would the
directors telling you when you were
going evil like how did they headed what
did you what did you what would inspire
your performance in that part of it um
the directors were really helpful they
really guided me into like and I think
they got they helped me get like really
angry and like pumped up my night yeah
because you do get angry at one point
and it's fun that was fun you play what
was it like working with Church the cat
no two cats right yeah uh it was really
cool cuz one second they would be like
really like friendly and then next
second they would have to be really like
angry and like aggressive and so is that
like who's that weird to watch huh well
I was kind of it was kind of cool
because I saw like how they got them
angry I think are you a cat lover or dog
lover um I really like dogs but um I
also find cats really sweet yeah and I
feel like right now a lot you know cats
are sort of having a moment you know on
the big ship you know and so what do you
think you know if you're talking to the
audience at home about church like what
you know what
what would you say to them about about
the cat in this movie um I think the I
think the trainers for the cats were
really good especially since cats are
like a little harder to Train than like
dogs so I think it was really cool to
see how they did that and I think the
trainers were really good what if like
this would have like a pet sematary like
this existed in real life would you ever
away would you ever kind of try it out
ah probably not because I think they may
be shares all the consequences of it
yeah I think there's death it still
shows how like the family deals with it
and that's pretty cool
and so if you were gonna talk to the
audience when they buy tickets for this
movie
what would you say why should they go
see it um they should go see it because
I mean it's very funny it has a lot of
comedy but it's also very like sweet at
some times so that's also really good
also has like it's very active it has a
lot of jump scares it also like deals
with the question like if someone close
to you died would you bring them back
and it's really cool to see how the
family deals with that question
throughout the movie and really sees
like the answer I guess
it was a myth kids used to dare each
other go into the woods at night they
knew the power of that place they feared
it those woods belong to something else
all right so you guys make some bold
changes to the material it's a bit of a
hot topic with this film at what point
did you have to convince Stephen King
that these were the right changes to
make What did he say did he give you
guys any notes oh the time when we had
to convince him with him when he watch
the hay but I mean that's what's so
great about him is that he he's had so
many books you know somebody movies
adapted from his work that guy's writes
like three novels a year I think he gets
to a point where he actually enjoys
people not transcribing his work but
adapting his work you know and some of
his favorite adaptations of ones that
did kind of stray from what he
originally wrote because as long as they
stick to the essence of what he's drawn
saying in his novel I think he gets that
and it was rewarding to see that he when
he finally sat down to watch the film he
got it
you know and he he was a fan of the
changes that he got behind it you know
because at the end of the day I think he
saw that we were still fundamentally
telling the story of Pet Sematary just
do a refreshed lens yeah so and you know
I feel like cats are having a bit of a
moment right now yeah on the big screen
you know talk about finding church
because it's a hard cat to cast it's got
to be the sweetest cat in the world the
most menacing cat in the world looks
very different from the church in the
original film yeah was it a hard cat
search um well we we were looking for a
cat that matched the cover of the
original hardcover you know so we were
going for that look and we went out and
we found some great cat trainers Kirk
and Melissa and we showed them the kind
of cat we want they went out
I put out there search and they found
rescue cats yeah rest was cast oh really
they all found homes after Ana they had
a team of cats that had this look and I
was like like you were saying I was like
it's a real specific look that rather of
some of these cats there's no way that
they're gonna just find a couple of cats
that look like this I could just do all
these things and then like between the
there was like four cats most of it was
split between two main cats lutonic and
Leo tonic being the nice playing the
nice cat at the beginning Leo playing
the evil cat and like you said you think
it would be hard but it was amazing
thank you I can't believe the things
that they had these cats do I just
showed up on set I was thinking never
work with animals they say and like you
know if these cats did amazing they
don't know if they don't ask what their
motivation is they know their
motivations food yeah you know I feel
like I'm some hero of this film is the
sound designer I think it's incredible
you're like the third person to mention
I think from from the truck noise to the
combing of the cat's hair everything
comes back you know just talk about how
important sound was super I mean we
actually had a conversation about that
when we met those guys I swear it was
the company that did that they did a
quiet place you know they were spirit
nominated for and I think they were
really impressed with his cattle and I
sat down with them and we just talked
about like the theories of sounds like
an hour plus over lunch you know and
about like watching the shining in film
school and being able to turn the
picture off and just listen to the sound
of the shining and understanding what
the story was through the sound and
being almost more frightened by the
sound than you were of the images so it
was always about you know sometimes what
you hear is scarier than what you see
and that's no better illustrator than
the chapter where they have to bury
Church and they take this long journey
into the heart of darkness where they
they go up in the mountains and that
chapter in the book you don't really see
anything you know you just you hear the
Windigo you hear treaties breaking and
stuff but you never really see anything
you know and so we wanted that to be a
really oughta Tori experience you know
so that the sounds of the trucks all
that stuff they just they mail that
stuff and I think that gets them to your
skin and gives you a better bus rule you
know reaction to the film
let's go hug your daughter I should
never have shown you that place your
child is not the only thing that will
come back
the barrier is broken alright so why is
right now the right time to bring Pet
Sematary back to the big screen I think
every generation has a different
relationship with death and I think we
sweep it under the carpet as much as we
can we keep it out of sight and I think
you gotta remember what it's about so I
think this was time you know I guess the
last one was 30 years ago time for a new
generation to experience what it's like
to defy death yeah you know you make
some bold changes in this film
what did Stephen King think about it
fortunately when he read the script he
was like it's really good and then when
he saw the movie not only did he really
like the movie but he was really blown
away by our actors yeah the performances
are really great they're fantastic
you know I think we're living in a time
where cats are having a bit of a moment
on the big screen you know church is an
iconic can't talk about finding the
right cat we sweated it you know one of
the funny things about it is like you go
back and look at the original cover of
the book and a lot of people say that's
what church is supposed to be which is a
particular kind of cat our directors are
cat lovers so the whole thing had this
whole drama to it which was awesome you
know it was not just finding the look
but it was also finding cats that
actually were a little bit trained yeah
so cats are not easy to train and in
fact we have was I was really worried
about with this movie it's like well
what happens if the cat doesn't do what
it's supposed to do
thankfully our trainer did a phenomenal
job you know and talking about some of
those changes what convinced you that
they were the right changes to make when
were you convinced well I think our
original writer Matt Greenberg but the
idea of switching the kids and one of
the reasons why I think that's a super
smart choice is it allows you to get
into the themes of the movie because you
can't have that conversation with a
three-year-old so that changes the whole
complexion of it because you can
actually talk about the things that this
movies about and I think that in
almost than anything else is the biggest
thing we did because it changed the
narrative of it in a way you know the
conversations between the adults amongst
themselves with the child and I think in
a way it made you understand even more
the irrational decisions that are made
and jete is a great fine how did where
did she come from Wow
it was amazing you know we were really
lucky we had several young ladies who
did a really good job but jeté had
something that it was interesting some
kids could do the really really scary
thing great or the really really sweet
thing but she's only want to really went
out there in both directions and it's a
demanding role why do you think people
need to go see this on the big screen I
think it's a group experience in many
ways you know because like a family
there's all these different elements in
it and everybody in the theater is
relating to a different character oh
that was my last moment I'm like as a
father or you know that ain't so I think
seeing that as a group is far more
satisfying you sort of feed off each
other yeah you know the original Pet
Sematary actually had a sequel is that
something that you've thought about it's
not really you know for me I always feel
like until you have a success it's
almost bad luck to think about it we'd
be lucky to have one I'm not really sure
where you'd go the only conversation
we've really had is there's a tremendous
amount of the book that is prior to this
movie so that probably if we did one
that'd be the arena we'd go into it'd be
a prequel I guess
you